Houston's famous livestock show and
rodeo is shut down this morning because
of concerns about the corona virus the
event was nine days into its 20-day run
when it was canceled yesterday it had
already drawn more than a half million
visitors this past weekend the rodeo was
the setting for a memorable homecoming
for Texas native and country music star
Maren Morris Morris and her husband
musician Ryan Hurd are about to welcome
their first child but that did not stop
her from performing in front of a nearly
sold-out Stadium audience the biggest of
her career Maren Morris is headlining
gig at the Houston Rodeo was anything
but a solo show
she was supported by a flock of sheep
during her soundcheck and the 29 year
old country star was performing nearly
nine months pregnant with her first
child I'm praying that he stays in there
for at least another 24 hours and then
he can fall out what is your actual due
date it's the 30th yeah so we're cutting
it pretty close but honestly I feel
great he's kicking but I I think we're
gonna be okay for today
the Houston Rodeo the biggest in the
world is an iconic event for any artist
but especially for a Texan Morris was
back in her home state rewarded with a
custom belt buckle I don't think a belt
will fit me right now as she huddled
with her band before her biggest show
ever we are about to play for like
63,000 people out there the massive star
shaped stage was rolled into the middle
of the arena and then Morris made her
entrance in the past few years she's
become one of the biggest stars in
country music and even crossed over to
pop success
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
kind of done this your own way does it
feel that way to you in some ways yeah I
haven't tried to follow anyone elses map
I've always had a really strong work
ethic because I've been playing since I
was so young Morris was 10 when she
started singing in Arlington Texas where
her parents run a hair salon at 21 she
packed up a u-haul and moved to
Nashville to become a songwriter where
we caught up with her in 2016 for CBS
Sunday morning
what was the scariest part about coming
here okay so I moved into like a
Craigslist house I didn't know who the
roommates were you said something to me
when we first met before years ago I
think it was God what no I just don't
want just happen since that interview I
had just moved into that house and there
was no like there was no furniture
there's like two chairs since then she's
had two number-one country albums
[Music]
and though few women get airtime on
country radio last month
Morris's song the bones hit number one
for two straight weeks
Morris asked her label the last time
that had happened for a female artist
and they said it was 2012 eight years
ago yeah and it was Carrie Underwood I
mean what does it say to you that it's
taken eight years for that to happen
again I could be like optimistic here
cautiously but I think that it's turning
for the better she's up for five Academy
of Country Music Awards next month
including female artist of the year and
group of the year that was a surprise
Reed is the high women the supergroup
she joined last year with Brandi Carlile
Amanda shires and Natalie hem be made
their debut at the Newport Folk Festival
last summer a moment I captured on my
cell phone I love that video you got
because that was if I can speak for all
of the ladies it was probably one of the
most special shows that we will ever
play why was it that special I think
because people were anticipating us and
excited to see us before we had even
played a note I just don't think we
expected that kind of love quite yet
Morris who's married to country singer
Ryan heard will go back on tour this
summer with a baby on board her tour bus
are you worried about that at all no I
mean I've just seen so many amazing
artists do it and make it look not only
normal for the child but fun we
continued that conversation backstage at
the rodeo
but we're interrupted this little baby
horse is peeing so loudly staring right
at you I i I've been there gotta pee all
the time
it's not often that your
conscious of a transitional moment in
your life I've had a lot of time off to
think about it so like the charm of
pregnancy has now worn off my husband
and I both just want to meet our kid but
I can't wait to look back at all this
footage from tonight years to come and
like show him my son this is what I did
like a week before you were here yeah
you were my duet partner through the
whole thing
[Music]
as if having one pregnant musician on
stage wasn't enough Morris's bass player
is actually also expecting any clements
six months pregnant with her first child
a baby girl Clemens got pregnant shortly
after Morris told the band about her
baby and now both women are planning to
take their newborns along on tour that
was remarkable because it to be that
pregnant yes anything is a miracle well
she said she got she got the offer
before she was pregnant and then when
she was looked at her due date she was
like oh you know but she brought her
doula along with her she had a whole
support team her family was there and
she snuck it in before the rodeo got
love seeing her as a ten-year-old and
then she's been doing it for a long time
and yeah that was a special time of that
folk festival yes it was and the BAL you
can hear the music yeah all right ahead
arm